je vous le disais dans les titres la
marche tourangelle prévu ce samedi à
l'occasion de la journée mondiale de
lutte contre l'homophobie et la
transphobie est finalement annulé le
centre lgbt y de touraine a décidé d'y
renoncer
compte tenu je cite des menaces et des
risques encourus par l'association mais
aussi pour toutes les personnes qui
souhaitaient s'y rendre la conclusion de
24 heures de polémique sur les réseaux
sociaux quant à l'interdiction possible
de la manifestation où personne blanche
on démêle le vrai du faux avec rémy
carton tout est parti d'une story
publiée sur le compte instagram du
centre lgbt y touraine
on peut y lire qu'un cortège non mixtes
sera présent à la marche de samedi une
zone où toute personne blanche présente
se ferait exclure relayée par le site
d'extrême droite fdesouche l'information
provoque un déchaînement de messages à
l'encontre des organisateurs sur les
réseaux sociaux
le centre lgbt y touraine reconnaît une
erreur de communication mais déplorent
les menaces pour l'association le
maintien de la marche aurait mis en
danger des participants la personne qui
a indiqué vouloir sur le cortège dans un
but malveillant
sans aucun doute on tâche est l'objectif
de cette visite est vraiment la
visibilité pour les personnes lgbt crise
leurs revendications et continue
d'appeler encore et jean à la solidarité
dans une lettre ouverte l'élu
d'opposition olivier lebreton a dénoncé
le cortège non mixtes
aujourd'hui il condamne les menaces mais
maintient ses critiques je compte bien
évidemment toutes les menaces évidemment
qu'il y ait pu avoir évidemment sur les
membres de cette association comme
ailleurs une menace quelque chose qui
est or notre pays notre pays on doit
parler librement
juste des choses les valeurs de la
république sont importantes et un moment
oui
la manifestation est annulée dans son
ensemble je ne demandais pas
l'annulation de la manifestation
je demandais juste l'annulation qu'il
n'y ait pas de cortège racisées et non
mixtes avant l'annulation le maire de
tours avait soutenu l'organisation de la
manifestation un soutien critiqué par
l'opposition
contacté le maire de tours n'a pas
souhaité réagir